Dr. Thomas Seafried speaks a lot on metabolic cancer and claims he has tested all the major
types of cancer.
It has determined that they all feed on a combination of glucose and glutamine.
He advocates clinical ketosis and push pulse therapy for short duration glutamine inhibitor
to kill off cancer cells.
He also says also low dose chemo can be used once in clinical ketosis.
I know you say that some cancers are not based on this fermentation process.
What are your thoughts on this approach?
Sounds like a combination with your protocols or with rife doesn't seem like considered
by standards of care even though there seems to be strong significant evidence of cancer
as a metabolic disease.
What are your thoughts?
So he's the guy who wrote cancer as a metabolic disease.
Now understand to define that, you know, just because cancer, so metabolic disease meaning
that really every disease is a metabolic disease except diseases that are specifically genetic
cause, which like if you're bored with down syndrome or something, that's not a metabolic
disorder.
You can't change a person's diet and change their down syndrome.
So of course every acquired disease is metabolic in origin.
He just kind of coined that phrase, cancer is a metabolic disease.
Nobody argued that it wasn't.
There are some cancers that are genetic, but it's a very small percentage of the cancers
that are genetic.
But when a person says, well, cancer is a metabolic disease, so you need to use ketosis, you
know, in a ketogenic diet to treat it, you're not equating one and one there just because
he wrote that book.
He advocates for ketogenic diet, doesn't mean that a ketogenic diet is going to solve
every metabolic disorder.
So a metabolic disorder means a disorder of cellular function.
So of course every disease is a disorder of cellular function.
Now, I would agree with him that, you know, most cancers feed on glucose and glutamine
and can switch back and forth.
So I would agree that that is the case.
The truth is all your cells feed on glucose through glycolysis.
They also can feed on fatty acid cycle because cell's purpose is to make energy.
So you need to make energy in order for cellular functions to take place.
So a cell's purpose is to make ATP.
So that's the energy that a cell makes.
Most efficient ways to make ATP is through glucose metabolism, breaking it down through glycolysis
and then through the cram cycle where it really kicks on ATP.
Also you can break down amino acids, also fatty acids.
So cancer can feed any different way.
The truth is cancer is going to do everything it can to feed any different way.
So it will change.
So is it wrong to go out of ketogenic diet?
No, it can be very beneficial to go out of ketogenic diet.
Because a person need to get in ketosis in order to shut down the glucose pathway.
No, that's not true either.
But the closer you could get to ketosis, the lower your glucose level.
You could get the lower levels of circulated glucose that you could have.
The benefit is going to be that the truth is nobody's ever going to have no glucose.
You need glucose.
Your brain is always going to need to feed off of glucose.
So if you didn't have any glucose, you would die.
But you don't want to supply excess glucose to cancer.
You don't want to supply excess fuel to a cancer cell.
Whether it's glucose or glutamate or amino acids or fatty acids or whatever that cancer has
acquired a taste for to feed off of.
So diet is important for cancer.
I would agree when you say that standards of care doesn't seem to address this issue.
I would totally agree with that.
Standards of care doesn't really address any metabolic disease.
Standards of care really doesn't address any chronic disorders well.
They don't deal with diet.
You see the rebergerator in a chemo center loaded with putting in, they recommend high sugar
drinks because they have a high caloric, it's just foolishness what standards of care
does.
But certainly switching between a ketogenic type diet and switching, trying to do things
to lower glutamate levels and methionate levels can be very beneficial.
And everybody's going to find what's going to be best for their cancer if they don't have
a way to test for that.